hello everyone so welcome to episode
number two of unlocking lily so I quit
my day job to pursue my dream in
becoming a public speaker and you guys
are all coming along with me for the
ride
so my first challenge was doing the
impress of video one of the most
important goals that I have is to become
a great storyteller I want to be able to
tell compelling stories where people
feel a little bit change after listening
to me so with the in spresso video I'm
able to take someone's message like when
Stefani's message in finding who you are
and use my own story to actually be able
to give you guys a teachable lesson good
morning belief nation today's message is
find who you are over to you Gwen
Stefani so when I first found out that I
will be talking about find who you are I
got so excited because being on the path
of self-discovery and self-awareness has
been so important to me and has been my
focus for the past two years I was so so
looking forward to actually sharing all
of that with you guys as well and in a
weird way I thought that Evan picked it
on purpose for me because he knew that
it would mean a lot I don't know maybe
that maybe he didn't maybe that's a
coincidence I will find out from him I
was really really happy about that this
has been a path of mine for the past few
years and I really wanted to share my
struggles my failures around it as well
as to let you know that things do get
better things doesn't always have to be
that way and I wanted you to learn from
my experiences so knowing all that I got
really excited on the day of and then it
took four hours I don't know what it is
with the camera being in front of your
face as soon as the camera is in front
of my face I feel
like I forget everything so all in all
it took two days to actually get the
entire video out for the first day I
spent two hours going over and over what
I'm going to say rehearsing it in my
head and out loud and then once I got in
front of the camera it took me another
two hours to actually record because I
still get very very nervous when the
cameras in front of my face right now I
feel really nervous and finally finally
28 times after I got the first final
draft I got really I was still I'm still
proud I'm so proud of myself and I'm
going to really send her up to Evan and
she's going to be so impressed with me
because you know I did such a good job
and everything what I did which I didn't
so I sent it over to him and he gave me
feedback so by the way all the videos
that you guys see on of me on his
channel he looked over he looked at it
before it actually goes live and he
sends me feedback of things that I need
to work on as well as he sends me
feedback on the things I did well as
well so he did the same thing for this
video but there was one thing in
particular that really just ah just got
to me was when he said that right now
you're seeing a lot of general things
and I don't feel what you're feeling and
that's the entire thing was it you know
I want to be a good storyteller
and he's not feeling what I'm feeling
that is not the point of this I haven't
done something right because of that and
then when I thought about was like okay
why why isn't he feeling what I'm
feeling at that moment
I realize that in order to have a
powerful story I have to be specific
about the moments in time I have to be
specific about that pivotal moment that
caused me to make a change to find out
who I am
so I suggested to be report and being
the really encouraging guy that he is he
said go for it so forth so the next day
after 24 hours of reflecting what
happened to cause that change I decided
to go in front of the camera and then
when I did I wasn't sure if I wanted to
share my story specifically with you
guys I was seeing too many general
things to dance around the idea of the
real hard-hitting questions and the
hard-hitting questions was what caused
me to change was I asked myself some
really really transparent questions
about myself I had to reveal that my job
at the time was making me miserable
I had to reveal a part of me that I
wasn't so proud of specifically the part
of me that picked a certain job because
she thought that money would make her
happy you know also seeing with a job
for so long knowing that you were
miserable you're unhappy and you have no
passion for it
you know what would people think of me
he was thinking like you know better why
and I was so afraid of getting judged
that I didn't want to share the
specifics of my story and then I started
thinking about like I really don't want
to hurt people's feelings either because
a lot of people that I worked with are
going to be watching my videos I don't
want them to think that you know I was
miserable when I was working there and
they had to do something they had
something to do with it or people who
are doing the same job as I was doing I
don't want them to think that is a bad
job or makes people miserable the only
reason why I was miserable because I was
doing something I did not have passion
and that's bad so I had to really really
wrestle with this idea like do I share
do I not share I don't know maybe I
should share another story and then I
came to the realization of something I
signed a contract with you guys the
first day when I got in front of the
camera and I told you that I'm going to
share everything about my journey with
you my failures my struggles my joy my
celebration everything
this means this story I have to tell you
the story what caused me to change
everything that I go through I can't
edit it I can't edit certain parts of my
life and show you certain part and show
I not show you certain parts I had to
share and I summed up the courage to
actually do the video the next day I did
I got a photo camera the next day and I
told my whole story around how I found
Who I am today
and I think the impact was so positive
because you guys responded to the video
in such loving emerging words and I
actually really want to share some of
the comments with you right now so the
first comment comes from staff reverance
this is amazing that's my Zumba teacher
I miss it so much guys but no worries I
will conquer any barrier and empower
myself out of this Congrats Lilly on her
debut on Evans channel Thank You Steph I
remember you you were the first one that
came to that Zumba class in December I
remember and I miss you too so if you
ever come to Toronto please come by
Toronto dance salsa and just come by and
visit say hi or take the path whatever
you want to do just come by okay I would
love to see you again the next line that
comes from Paulo min and says OMG Lilly
I am so proud of you people can feel
your genuine personality and this will
take you so so far good for you girl
Paul eminences is one of the first
people to actually write on my intro
video as well so Paulo
honestly your your feedback and your
encouragement and your words mean so so
much to me so thank you so much Paulo
the last one comes from an elastic oh
one while Lily you made me cry but your
words truly hit home keep up the good
work
elastic oh one now that you know that I
struggled really hard with whether or
not I should tell my whole story with
you guys your words right now made me
feel more confident that I did the right
thing so Scholastica won thank you again
for writing this comment so those are
the three but I do have one honorable
mentions I was not on YouTube especially
on Facebook it comes from my mom my mom
recently discovered social media and
she's been quite she's been very very
active on it and she wrote on the video
that have been shared on Facebook was
amazing what - smiley face emojis my mom
is so funny
and she's so humorous and such a
wonderful human being and she honestly
is the most generous person I have ever
known in my life she's the reason why I
can give and she taught me one very
important lesson is to always give
without expecting anything in return and
I will always take it everywhere with me
so mom thank you so much I love you
so my challenge for next week is to
research 20 inspirational speakers that
I look up to so right now I have this
big goal right the big goal of stepping
on stage and speaking to thousands of
people but I don't really know which
specific path I can take and the truth
is I can figure everything out on my own
I can you know but it will take me a
very long time it will take me maybe
five years 10 years 15 years I don't
know and the truth is a lot of times you
and I don't have that kind of time to
actually figure things out so the best
thing to do in that case is to actually
look at people who have gone through
what we want to go through whatever that
mission is in my case is being a public
speaker and see what their breakthroughs
were and see what there are hot moments
were and see their mistakes so that way
we don't make the same mistake as well
so that's going to be all next week I'm
going to share with you my research I'm
going to share with you all the
breakthroughs that these people have and
how my path is going to change or
develop as a result of it especially
have a question for you guys when was
the last time you shared a specific
story with someone and if you're willing
and comfortable I would love to see it
in the comments of what the story was
you guys have been so open with your
stories and I love reading it so if the
more stories you share that's better and
I'll be looking forward in waiting all
your comments below once again I am so
so incredibly grateful for all the
wonderful comments the love the
encouragement and support that's been
pouring in over the past couple weeks
you guys are incredible I couldn't ask
or more thank you thank you so much and
I will see you guys very soon